rocket league is a perfect combination
of calculated action and unexpected
chaos the idea of playing soccer with
cars is itself a good one but it's the
way that rocket league feels that makes
it so fun to play ludicrous speed
perfectly controlled cars and goofy
floaty physics interactions turn every
play into a melding of intelligent
execution and unpredictable luck any
version of rocket league on a mobile
device would have to capture that same
feeling and it's remarkable how much
rocket league sideswipe a scaled down
super quick mobile take on the rocket
league concept captures exactly what
makes its full size counterpart so
enjoyable
sideswipe succeeds in creating a
conception of rocket league that caters
to mobile play this is a platform where
time is spent in short bursts and where
the best games are those that find a
sweet spot between solid control and
decreased complexity for developer
psionics that sweet spot is found by
taking the fundamentals of rocket league
and flattening them into a 2d version of
the 3d game this is still soccer with
cars or basketball with cars depending
on the playlist you choose but instead
of covering a whole 3d soccer field you
instead only have to deal with the
action on a single plane the side on
view of the field means that a few
elements of rocket league work
differently in the mobile version you
can't crash into other cars for instance
only the ball the floors and the wall
affect your vehicle in motion and since
goals can't be horizontal they instead
extend vertically into the air with a
lip at the top and bottom requiring you
to give your shots a little lift in
order to score though playing a
two-dimensional version of rocket league
sounds like it could rob the game of the
fundamentals of its skill based play the
reality is that flattening the game
works perfectly in the 3d game rocket
league is about controlling the space
using rocket boosters to chase the ball
in the air and find unexpected angles of
attack but the verticality of the 2d
field maintains a lot of the same
feeling thanks in large part to the way
the controls have translated between the
bigger game and its smaller incarnation
cars handle pretty much exactly the way
they do in the original rocket league
with powered dodge maneuvers giving you
a little extra momentum or providing the
feeling of a kick and rocket boosters
that can speed you into position or send
you through the air the 2d approach and
vertical goal means that most of
sideswipe is airborne and the floaty
physics of rocket league translate
exceptionally well to this approach
rocket league is largely about getting
good at the way you can make your car
fly and how it handles in the air and
the same is true of sideswipe the skill
and challenge of the game comes in
getting your small car into the right
spot to stop a big shot or tap in a goal
because the 2d space maintains that
focus on flying sideswipe still feels
great in a lot of the same ways as the
larger game though this version of the
competition is simplified the key
elements of learning the peculiarities
of making cars fly anticipating the
game's physics and making huge plays
comes through perfectly
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
what makes it all work is how responsive
sideswipes controls are psionics has
done a phenomenal job of bringing the
fast pace and airborne nature of rocket
league to a 2d space a small screen and
touch controls slide swipe packs three
buttons the equivalent of an analog
stick for directing your car's nose and
thus determining where you drive or how
it flies a button that you can double
tap to activate the flipping dodge move
and a booster button that activates your
rockets again simplicity is on the
game's side here because you're really
only tapping one button and using your
other thumb to direct your car the 2d
presentation and touch controls work
exceedingly well together the size of
the field relative to your car means
that there's lots of space to put your
thumbs without feeling like you're
covering the action and since you're
only determining where your car is
pointing on x and y axes the thumb stick
touch control is just about pointing
yourself where you want to go everything
feels tight and responsive despite the
lack of physical buttons and because
things are relatively simple you won't
find yourself losing track of the
positions of the controls on screen
without the benefit of feeling them
still sideswipe is at its best when you
connect a controller to your mobile
device as good as the touch controls are
there's a serious benefit to the tactile
feedback of directing an actual
thumbstick or pressing a physical button
as is the case with all touch control
games you eventually move your thumb too
far in one direction or another and need
to reposition for proper control the
limits of touch controls create
something of a skill ceiling that the
benefits of a controller make it
possible to surpass
sideswipe currently includes three game
modes all of which are ranked duels duos
and hoops the first two are standard one
on one and two on two matches
respectively with the fields adjusted
slightly to make scoring a bit easier
when you don't have a teammate backing
you up in a duels match hoops brings in
the rocket league alternate mode of
basketball with cars requiring you to
drop the ball into a goal from above it
plays just differently enough to offer a
little variety to the game experience
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
when you search for games you can choose
which of the three playlists are
included allowing you to just go after a
certain kind of experience or mix them
all together each variation is just
enough of an alteration to the formula
to keep things fresh and interesting
without overstaying its welcome thanks
to the fact that matches only last two
minutes at a time at the moment
sideswipe is a free-to-play game with no
means of monetization although the bones
of systems where you could pay into the
game are definitely present completing
matches win or lose earns you experience
points which earn you in-game currency
and unlock cosmetic rewards along a
battle pass like reward track there are
also a series of challenges you can
complete that give you xp bonuses things
like win 3 duels matches or play 5
matches with a particular car none are
really all that difficult but they do
give you a little something to focus on
as you play the progression system also
clips right along dishing out lots of
little cosmetic rewards along the way
that give you some incentive to play
other than increasing your rank in each
of the activities one assumes the game
will adopt some sort of monetization
structure in the future and it'll
probably be similar to that of the
original rocket league's paid rocket
pass structure but we'll have to wait
and see how that might affect the game
right now though rocket league sideswipe
is a blast it's a downsized version of
rocket league that streamlines and
shrinks the experience without
sacrificing its fundamental nature it
also brilliantly takes advantage of the
mobile medium with super quick games
easy to understand mechanics and
excellent controls sideswipe is a
smaller quicker lighter weight version
of rocket league that still captures why
the original is so endearing and it's
absolutely a game you should make space
for on your phone
you